3 สวัสดีค่ะครูนิกสวัสดีครับครูหญิง
สวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนด้วยสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนครูนิกวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้ครับที่
อเมริกานะครับเป็นวันพฤหัสบค่ะวันนี้วัน
พฤหัสบวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 3 ครับ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤศจิกายนปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศครับ
256  5 ค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ครับค่ะตอนนี้ที่อเมริกากี่โมแล้ว
คะตอนนี้นะครับ
เวลา 19:00 น
26 นาอืตอนกลางคืนเวลากลางคืนใช่ใช่แล้ว
นะคะก็แต่ว่าที่ไทยเนี่ยวันนี้วันที่ 4
นะคะวันนี้วันศุกร์เรวใช่เร็ว
กว่าเยอะนะคะเรียกกว่า 12 ชมงเนาะเพราะ
ว่าตอนนี้ที่
ไทย 7 นเช้าแล้วอืมตอน
เช้าใช่ตอนเช้านะคะแล้วก็ตอนนี้ 19:30 น
ประมาณเนาะประมาณนะคะประมาณ 19:30 นเนี่ย
ครูนิกกินข้าวหรือยังคะครูนิกกินข้าวแล้ว
ครับอืครูนิกกินอะไรบอกได้มั้ย
คะครูนิกกินอะไรครูนิกเนี่ย
กินกินฮอตดอก
อืใช่คือที่กินฮอตดอกเนี่ยเพราะว่ามัน
เป็นของที่อยู่ในตู้เย็นคือครูนิกอ่ะอยาก
จะเอาของในตู้เย็นน่ะให้มันหมดก็เลยคือ
ขี้เกียจออกไปซื้อของในซูเปอร์มาร์เก็ต
แล้วแบบเออก็มีไส้กรอกกับขนมปลา
เลยคุยกับแฟนว่าเออทำฮอตดอกกินมยอืใช่
อุ๊ยงั้นก็ครูนิกก็เป็นคนกินง่ายนี่คะฟัง
นะฟังแล้วดูแบบเออก็ดูกินง่ายๆเปิดตู้
เย็นมาอ๊มีอะไรอ๊มีฮอตดอกมีขนมปังมีไส้
กรอบโอเคแล้วก็กิน
อื
ก็ไม่ง่ายจริงๆจะบอกว่าง่ายม
ก็ก็ได้มั้งครับคือครูนิกเนี่ยบอกว่าคุณ
นิกอ่ะจะจะคิดว่าตัวเองเนี่ยเป็นคนกิน
ง่ายแต่คนรอบข้างคุณนิกเนี่ยจะบอกว่าไม่
นะไม่ง่ายเ้าทำไมอ่ะจากเดี๋ยวจากครูหญิง
ฟังเนี่ยนะคะครูหญิงก็คิดว่าครูนิกเป็นคน
กิน
ง่าย
อืคือสำหรับคครูนิกเนี่ยถ้าอยู่ที่บ้านนะ
ครับคือครูนิกก็จะไปซื้อของใน
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตก็จะไปซื้อของคุณนิกชอบ
ทำกับข้าวแล้วพอซื้อของมาก็จะเก็บเก็บไว้
ในตู้เย็น
แล้วคุณนี้ิก็จะดูว่าเอ๊ะวันนี้อยากกิน
อะไรตอนเที่ยงอยากกินอะไรแล้วก็ทำกับข้าว
กินเราก็จะดูแค่
ของที่มันอยู่ในตู้เย็น
อืแต่ถ้าไปข้างนอกกินข้าวที่ร้านอาหาร
เนี่ยคุณนี้ก็จะต้องคิดนิดนึงละ
ว่ายกตัวอย่างว่าถ้าไปเที่ยว 1 วันค่ะถ้า
ตอนตอนเที่ยงกิน
KFC อืกินไก่ใช่มใช่กินไก่ทอดตอนเย็น
เนี่ยครูนิกจะไม่กิน 2 ทอดละ
อ๋อก็คืออะไรก็ได้ที่ทอดเหมือน KFC ก็คือ
ไม่กินก็คือไม่กินะเพราะคิดว่ากินไปแล้ว
ตอนเที่ยงถ้ากินตอนเย็นอีกเนี่ยมันจะมัน
จะไม่ดีมันจะสุขภาพเรามันจะไม่ดีเพราะกิน
แต่ของทอดแล้วก็ของทอดใช่
อืแล้วครูนิกมีอะไรที่ไม่กินมอ่ะเพราะว่า
บางคนเนี่ยถ้ามีคนบอกว่านิกนิกเป็นคนกิน
ยากนะไม่ได้กินง่ายก็แปลว่าเราเนี่ยมี
อะไรที่แบบอออันนี้ไม่กินไม่กินไม่กินไม่
กินไม่กินไม่กินไม่เอาไม่ใส่อันเนี้ยคนก็
จะบอกว่าทำไมกินยากจังอันนี้ก็ไม่กินอัน
นี้ก็ไม่กินครับของครูนิกมีมีของที่ครู
นิกเนี่ยไม่กินค่ะก็ท้าง่ายๆเลยนะครับ
ครุณนิกเนี่ยเป็นคนกินผลไม้น้อยมากอืม
แอปเปิ้ล
สตรอเบอร์รี่ไม่กิน
คือจริงๆแล้วแอปเปิ้ลกิน
ได้
สตอเบอร์รีู่นัไม่ครูนี้คะเวลาอยู่ประเทศ
ไทยเนี่ยสตรอเบอร์รี่แพงมากผู้หญิงไป
อเมริกานะต้องกินสตรอเบอร์รี่หรือว่าไป
ประเทศไหนก็ได้เพราะมันถูกใช่มถ้าอยู่
ข้างนอกประเทศไทยคือครูนิกเนี่ยจะไม่ค่อย
ชอบกินอะไรที่มันหวานๆถ้าไม่ใช่เคกนะอค่ะ
อเพราะ
คือผลไม้เนี่ยคุณนี้จะกินผลลผลไม้ที่มัน
เปรี้ยว
อื
ใช่ซตมบางครั้งมันหวานแล้วบางครั้งมัน
หวานบางครั้งมันเปรี้ยวแบบกินแล้วแบบ
เปรี้ยวเออแต่ถ้าส้มครับส้มกินมั้ยคะส้ม
เปรี้ยวส้มกินถ้าไม่มี
เม็ดโอเคเข้าใจ
แล้ว
เข้าใจแล้วว่าทำไมทุกคนบอกว่าครูนิกกิน
ยากส้มกินแต่ถ้าไม่มีเม็ดก็คือเวลากินส้ม
แล้วแบบอืมเม็ดส้มอันเนี้ยถ้างั้นครูนิก
อยู่ประเทศไทยก็ไม่กินส้มสิคะจะกินส้มถ้า
เป็นน้ำปั่นเนี่ยๆอันเนี้ยเม็ดส้มใช่มั้ย
คะครับถ้าเป็นน้ำปั่นหรือน้ำส้มเนี่ยจะ
กินเพราะมันไม่มี
เม็ดแต่ไม่แต่ครูหญิงมันมีส้มเหมือนที่
ไทยก็น่าจะเหมือนกับเป็นส้มเช้งอ่ะส้ม
เช้งกินง่าย
อเอ่อส้มเช้งมันมีเม็ดมั้ยส้มเช้งเนี่ย
ครุณนิกคิดว่ามันก็
มีแต่ว่ามันจะเอาออกง่ายกว่าอืเดี๋ยวปกติ
อ้อจริงจริงๆมันก็ไม่ค่อยมีเม็ดเท่าไหร่
นะคะครูนิกอ่ะเดี๋ยวครูหญิงเปิดส้มเช้ง
ให้นักเรียนดู
ครับนี่ใช่มั้ยคะส้มเฉงใช่ๆคิดว่าไม่น่า
จะมีมั้งครับแต่คือถ้ามีก็คือน้อยมากจริง
ๆเออเนี่ยดูสิไม่มีเม็ดเลยแต่นี้ส้มเช้ง
อร่อยนะใช่ก็เนี่ยก็จะ
อจะกินอ่ะแต่ถ้าสมมุติว่าเป็นเนื้อสัตว์
อย่างไก่อย่างเงี้ยปกติทุกคนจะกินไก่ใช่
ไหมมคะไก่อย่างเงี้ยครูนิกกินได้ทุกส่วน
เลยมย
ไก่ไก่จริงๆแล้วกินได้ทุกส่วนแต่ถ้าให้
เลือกจะไม่กินอกไก่อันนี้เหมือนกันคนไทย
ตรงนี้มั้ยอ่ะมันอยู่ตรงช่วงนี้มั้ยอกอก็
ก็คืออยู่ทั้งทั้งหมดทั้งข้างบนนี่แหละ
ครับนี่เนาะอืช่วงนี้นะคะเนื้ออกไก่อืก็
ไม่กินแล้วหนังไก่อ่ะคะเนี่ยหนังไก่คุณ
นี้ก็กินใช่มั้ยอหนังไก่เนี่ยชอบ
มากครับของทอดู้หิงมีรูปอยู่นะอ่ะไม่ใช่
อันนี้นี่ค่ะหนังไก่ทอดนี้สั่งมาเลยถ้าไป
ร้านอาหารเอามาเลย 10 จานคุนิกกินกินๆครู
นิกอ่ะจำได้เลยตอนเด็กๆนะตอนตัวเล็กๆคูณ
นิกไปกินข้าวมันไก่บอกเขาว่าเอาข้าวมัน
หนังไก่ไม่เอา
เนื้อคือครูนิสั่งข้าวมันไก่ที่เอาแต่
หนังอ่ะนะคะใช่ครับเค้าทำให้มั้ยครูนิกทำ
เค้าทำให้เค้าก็จะคิดแค่เค้าก็จะคิดราคา
เท่ากันเลย
ครับอ๋อครูนิกก็คือสั่งข้าวมันไก่แล้วก็
เอาแค่หนังไก่แบบเนี้ยถ้าสมมุติก็คือคุณ
เอาแค่หนังเนี่ยเนื้อตรงนี้ก็คือไม่เอา
อือฮึใช่เพราะชอบคือเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยอันนี้
มันก็พอคิดแล้วมันก็ตลกดีเพราะว่าตอนคุณ
นิกเด็กๆก
เนี่ยไม่รู้ว่าคิดอะไรคุณนี้ก็อยากมี
พุง
มีผุงก็คือเดี๋ยวครูหญิงวาดครูนิกให้นะคะ
สมมุติอันนี้เป็นครูนิกใช่มั้ยถ้ามองข้าง
ๆก็คือมีผุงเป็นพุงเป็นชั้นๆแบบ
เนี้ยทำไมอ่ะทำไมครูนิถึงอยากมีุอันนั้น
มันเป็นความคิดตอนเด็กๆหรือเปล่ารู้สึก
ว่าเหมือนหมีพูหรือเปล่าคะ
คืออันนี้พอพูดแล้วก็ตลกตัวเองคือตอนเด็ก
ๆเนี่ยคุณนิก
อะไปเห็นไอ้ตัว
มิชลินแล้วคุณนิกเออจริงๆถ้าอ้วนก็ดูน่า
รักดีเนาะเพราะมันมีพุงแล้วพอนั่งแล้วมัน
เป็นชั้นๆชั้นๆเหมือนมิชลินใช่ตอนนี้ล
มิชลินตอนนี้ไม่อยากไม่อยากมี
พุงแล้วตอนนั้นเนี่ยอะไรที่มันๆคุณนิกกิน
หมดเลย
อืทอดหนังไก่คุณนิกไปสั่งก๋วยเตี๋ยวอ่ะ
พวกเอ่อบะหมี่แห้งบะหมี่ก็คือเป็นเส้น
ก๋วยเตี๋วสีเหลืองๆใช่มยครับคุณนิก็แบบ
บหมี่แห้งใส่น้ำมันน่ะเยอะๆ
หูใช่ใช่เพราะว่าเวลาก๋วยเตี๋ยวแห้งๆ
เนี่ยเขาจะใส่น้ำมันลงไปคลุกใช่มยคะน้ำ
มันที่เอาไว้ทอดอ่ะอืเพราะว่าอยากเป็น
เหมือนมิชลินใช่ใช่
อืเออน้องครูหญิงเข้าใจแล้วล่ะค่ะที่
เพื่อนๆครูนิกบอกว่าจริงๆแล้วเอครูนิก
เป็นคนกินยาก
นะเออเพราะว่าอย่างอย่างครุหญิงอย่าง
เงี้ยค่ะก็คิดเหมือนครูนิกนะว่าแบบเฮ้ย
เราเป็นคนกินอะไรก็ได้กินอะไรก็ได้ก็คือ
อาหารไม่อร่อยอ่ะก็กินได้สมมุติว่าอไปทำ
อาหารไปไปร้า้าอาหารอย่างเงี้ยค่ะไม่
เลือกว่าโอเคร้านนี้ดูแล้วอืคนน้อยไม่
อร่อยน่าจะไม่อร่อยแตุ่หญิงกินได้อ่ารู้
สึกว่าเออกินอะไรก็ได้เหมือนลิ้นก็คือ
ลิ้นกินอะไรก็ได้อ่ะค่ะก็เลยคิดว่าตัวเอง
เนี่ยเป็นคนกินง่าย
อืแต่ว่าอคุณนิกอ่ะได้มยคะจริงๆก็จริงๆก็
ได้นะครับแต่คือ
ช่วงนี้เนี่ยครูนิกเวลาจะไปข้างนอกหรือ
กินข้าวข้างนอกเนี่ยครูนิกจะดูใน Google
ว่ามันมีร้านอาหารอะไรแล้วพอดูแล้วเออ
เค้าบอกว่าดีหลายๆคนบอกว่าดีก็
ไปมันก็เลยส่วนใหญ่ครูนิก็จะใช้ Google
เวลาหาร้านอาหารแต่ถ้าเดินๆอยู่แล้วเจอ
ร้านอาหารแล้วหิว
ถ้าต้องกินมันก็ต้องกินอืใช่ครับอืแต่ว่า
โดยปกติแล้วเนี่ยจะหาร้านอาหารก่อนจากใน
Google ว่าอุ๊ยร้านนี้ดูดีน่ากินอ่าแต่
ครูหญิงเนี่ยจริงๆถ้าครูนิกบอกว่าเออมา
กินร้านนี้กินร้านนี้ครูหญิงก็โอเคกินได้
อ่าก็คือแบบกินอะไรก็ได้ก็คิดว่าตัวเอง
อ่ะกินง่ายๆแบบนั้นแต่จริงจริงๆแล้วก็คือ
ร้านเวลาไปกินมันก็เหมือนกับอุ๊ยอันนี้
เราไม่กินน่ะคือผู้หญิงจะกินอาหารอยู่ไม่
กี่อย่างไงคะอืกินข้าวกิน
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวครับกินสปาเกตตี้งเงี้ยกินหรือ
ว่าราเมงบะหมี่กินแต่อาหารอินเดียอาหาร
เม็กซิโกอาหารอาหารประเทศอื่นๆที่ไม่ใช่
เอเชียแล้วก็ไม่ใช่อาหารอิตาลีอย่างเงี้ย
ไม่กินอ๋อออคือแบบคุณนี้กินคุณนี้กิน
อาหารหลาย
ที่มากคิดว่าที่ยังไม่เคยกินน่าจะเป็น
อาหาร
ของอ่าแอฟริกาที่ยังไม่เคยหรอกอออือืครู
หญิงก็ไม่เคยเหมือนกันค่ะหรือว่าถ้าครู
นิกบอกว่าอ่ะครูหญิงไปร้านอาหารเม็กซิโก
อ่ะคุหญิงได้แต่พอไปถึงถึงเปิดดูเมนูขุ
หิงอาจจะไม่กินอาหารเม็กซิโกก็ได้ค่ะอาจ
จะกินถ้าร้านนั้นมีเฟรนช์ฟรายก็คือกินอ่า
อย่างเงี้ยแบบเหมือนแบบเออเราเป็นคนคิด
ว่าเราเป็นคนกินง่ายนะแต่เราเลือกมากว่า
แบบอ๋ออันนี้ไม่กินน่ะอันนี้ไม่กินอันนี้
ไม่กินอันนี้ไม่กินแต่เป็นคนกินอาหารที่
ทำง่ายๆมากกว่าอเหมือนใช่เหมือนที่ไทยอ่ะ
ค่ะมันจะมีอาหารอยู่เมนูนึงก็คือต้มเลือด
หมูไม่รู้ครูนี้ิชอบกินหรือเปล่านะคะต้ม
เลือดหมู
ชอบชอบใช่มย
ใช่คือต้มเลือดหมูเนี่ยนะคะมันจะมี
อันเนี้ยไส้หมูนะคะนักเรียนอันนี้ตับหมู
ครับอัน
นี้กระเพาะไม่แน่ใจกระเพาะใช่มยเวลาที่
เรากินแล้วไปย่อยอาหารนะคะแล้วก็เนี่ยย
เนื้อหมูส่วนนักเรียนเห็นแดงๆเนี่ยค่ะคือ
เลือดหมูอือันนี้คือหมูกรอบนะคะนักเรียน
อันนี้อร่อยมากนะคะตรงนี้นะคะอร่อย
มากก็ไม่ดีเนาะเนี่ยหึกำลังจะบอกว่าอัน
นี้นี่เป็น
เกาเหลาเป็นต้มเลือดหมูที่มันมีใบกัญชา
หรือเปล่าอันนี้ใช่สิอันนี้มันคือใบอะไร
นะไม่ใช่กัญช้าคือตอนแรกคูนี้คิดว่าเอ๊ะ
มันไม่ใช่คลื่นช่านะ
แต่มันคือใบอะไรล่ะกัญชามันเป็นยังไงก็
ไม่รู้ด้วยนะเนี่ยครูหญิงเนี่ยเหมือน
เมเปิ้ลมั้ยกัญชาใช่ก็ครูิกก็คิดแว่าเอ๊ะ
ใบกัญชามันจะเหมือนธงแคนาดา
เออ
เออไม่ใช่ค่ะูนิอันนี้ครูหญิงจำไม่ได้นะ
ใบอะไร
แต่จริงจูฉาย
หรอไม่รู้เลยอ่ะเมื่อก่อนครูเอ๋เคยบอกแต่
ตอนนี้จำไม่ได้นะคะก็ก็เนี่ยต้มเลือดหมู
ครูหญิงเป็นคนชอบกินต้มเลือดหมูนะคะแต่
ว่าเวลาสั่งต้มเลือดหมูก็คือไม่เอาเลือด
หมูอืแต่ร้านเค้าก็ทำให้นะอืก็โอเค
ใช่ของคูนิกเนี่ยถ้าไปกินก๋วยเตี๋ยวนะค่ะ
หรือพวกต้มแบบนี้ครับคุณนิกอ่ะคุณนิกไม่
ชอบผักชีอ่าอ่านี่ไงๆไงนี่ไงเอชายอันนี้
เห็นมั้ยคะนักเรียนนักเรียนบอกครูหญิง
เปิดได้มยไอ้เขียวๆที่เป็นแบบสับๆอืเออออ
แต่ว่าคุณหญิงเคยได้ยินนะคนส่วนใหญ่ไม่
ค่อยชอบผักชีอ่ะ
คะแต่ที่ตลกคือนี่คุนิกอ่ะไม่กินผักชีแต่
คุณนิกกินต้น
หอมใช่ค่ะปกติคนไม่ค่อยกินต้นหอมผักชีก็
จะไม่ไม่กินคู่กันเลยมยแต่คุณนิกจะกินต้น
หอมแต่ผักชีอ่ะไม่กินค่ะเคยมีนะ 1 ท้อง
คือตอนเด็กๆไปร้านก๋วยเตี๋ยวแล้วเขาใส่
ผักชีกับต้นหอมด้วยกันอแล้วบอกแม่ค้าว่า
เอาแต่ต้นหอมได้มยแม่ค้าโอเคมยคะก็ก็โอเค
เพราะว่าแม่ค้าเนี่ยเป็นเพื่อนกับแม่
เดี๋ยวคุนิปกติติเเนี่ยในสมมุติมันมีถ้วย
1 ถ้วยใช่มั้ยคะร้านก๋วยเตี๋ยวเนี่ยเขา
จะซอยซอยซอยต้นหอมแล้วก็ซอยผักชี้เล็กๆ
เนี่ยใส่ไว้ในถ้วยอ่ะสมมุติว่ามันจะมี
ถ้วยนี้ใช่มั้ยคะก็จะมีครึ่งนึงเนี่ยผัก
ชีอผักชีอีกครึ่งนึงต้นหอมครับมันจะอยู่
ในถ้วยเดียวกันเขาก็จะหยิบแล้วมันจะปนกัน
ไม่ใช่หรอใช่ใชู่นิกบอกว่าเอ่อ
เอาแต่ต้น
หอมแม่ค้าก็แบบเพราะว่าเป็นเพื่อนแม่ก็
โอเคแต่ถ้าไม่ใช่เพื่อนแม่เขาก็จะแบบไม่
ต้องกินกินยากนักก็ไม่ต้อง
กินแต่คุณนิกก็จะแค่ขอเวลาร้านก๋วยเตี๋ยว
ที่เป็นเพื่อนแม่อย่างเดียวถ้าไปที่อื่นแ
ล่ากลัวอืคุนิก็บอกว่าอ๋อไม่เอาต้นหอมผัก
ผัก
ชีเข้าใจแล้วค่ะว่านั่นแหละเนี่ยแบบเนี้ย
เราจะรู้สึกว่าเฮ้ยเราเป็นคนกินง่ายนะแต่
เราจะมีบางอย่างที่แบบไม่เอาไม่ใส่อันนี้
ถ้าใส่สมมุติใส่ผักชีอืไม่กินอือใส่ผักชี
ไม่กินนะมันมันก็เลยคนก็เลยบอกว่าอุ๊ยกิน
ยากเราเนี่ยเป็นคนกินยากนะคะแต่เราก็จะ
บอกว่าโอ๊ยไม่ยากไม่ยากใช่เพราะเราก็คิด
ว่าตัวเรากินง่ายๆไงใช่ไม่เห็นยากเลยเรา
กินอะไรก็ได้นะแต่อันนี้ไม่กินพิซซ่าไม่
พิซซ่าถ้าใส่ผักชิอันนี้ไม่กินอันนี้อัน
นี้ก็ไม่กินสปาเกตตี้ต้องเส้นเล็กๆนะ
สปาเกตตี้เส้นใหญ่ๆออไม่กินอ่าก๋วยเตี๋ยว
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวเส้นเล็กเส้นต้องแบบดีๆถ้าเส้น
แบบดึ๋งๆไม่กินใช่อันเนี้ยกินยนะคะนัก
เรียนถ้าไปกับเพื่อนเพื่อนก็บอกว่าเออไม่
ต้องมาอีกแล้วนะครั้งเดียวพอแล้วแล้ว
เพื่อนก็บอกอยู่บ้านนะทำเอง
ใช่โอเคใช่แล้วนักเรียนล่ะคะนักเรียนเป็น
คนกินง่ายๆหรือว่าเป็นคนกินยากแบบอันนี้
ก็ไม่กินอันนี้ก็ไม่กินอันนี้ก็ไม่กินนะ
คะก็คอมเมนต์บอกเราได้เนาะแต่ว่าวดีโอนี้
นะคะก็หมดเวลาแล้วครับ
โอเคไว้เจอกันใหม่ในครั้งต่อไปได้ค่ะคุณ
นิกสวัสดีค่ะครับสวัสดี
ครับ